I've dated multiple women 6 ft tall and
I'm 5'5 have you always been good with
women our whole life at what age did you
realize hey
maybe a lot of it's confidence I think
what they're attracted to is your
personality and the way you car yourself
so if you just naturally have like an
aura about you of like I don't give a
how tall I am and trust me you're
not going to regret dating me they don't
give a nobody really does yeah do
you think your height has held you back
or made it better for you in such a way
that you stand out I'd say I don't think
about it I think if we were 6 with these
personalities it would be
scary I think God only gives you so much
you know